la guerre est toujours là quelque chose
d'intéressant qui qui s'est passé il y a
eu la visite du seasing donc les
dirigeants chinois à Moscou je sais pas
si vous avez suivi oui donc à Moscou et
lierre Poutine a déclaré qu'il va
installer les armes nucléaires tactiques
en Biélorussie alors c'est quoi ça leur
raconte nous et ben voilà mais ça vous
souvenez il y a un an quand même
c'est un gros bail ça c'est c'est c'est
un énorme une énorme information mais
sauf que là
est-ce que tu peux expliquer les armes
tactiques c'est c'est les petites armes
qui qui ne sont pas énormes qui ne
produisent pas les énormément de dégâts
mais qui qui sont quand même donc le
nucléaires et si jamais Poutine les
employés bah ils franchiraient la ligne
rouge dans le monde entier on en a pas
on en parle depuis un an et là il y a 6
INPI qui est venu à Moscou et Poutine
lui a dit promis juré je ne parle plus
d'armes nucléaire je les utilise pas si
INPI repart et là Poutine lui dit
annonce qu'il va mettre ses armes en
Biélorussie donc il s'est passé quelque
chose de mal entre la Chine et la Russie
ça s'est passé mal pour routine ça c'est
chaud parce que
la Chine c'était notre dernier euh en
fait c'est ça c'est ça ce qui c'est
c'est passé c'est que Poutine a demandé
à sidine pin de lui fournir des armes et
apparemment Poutine et ses INPI lui a
dit non et donc du coup lorsque il est
reparti Poutine dire ah recommencer à
parler des armes nucléaires mais juste
Sergueï parce que c'est vrai que tant
mieux on en parle plus
mais non mais arrête ça peut aller où
cette histoire bah ça peut aller il y en
a pour tout parce que en fait Poutine on
parle de piano un peu plus d'un an on a
commencé vous souvenez le 24 février
j'étais sur votre plateau
2000-2022 et quand je vous ai parlé de
ces armes tactiques vous étiez tous
effrayés bien sûr en disant mais
qu'est-ce que c'est cette histoire et
trois jours après de lui il a dit je
peux les utiliser et donc en fait il en
parle toutes les semaines toutes les
semaines elle remet une couche sauf
qu'il y a six INPI qui lui a dit arrête
de faire ça il lui a dit ça déjà au mois
de septembre ça marquante et puis il est
allé le voir directement à Moscou en
disant vous Vladimir ça c'est la ligne
rouge pour la Chine absolue ça veut dire
que si tu reparles des armes nucléaires
et si tu surtout si tu les utilises la
Chine va te lâcher et la Chine c'est le
seul partenaire qui reste à Poutine
parce que sans la Chine économiquement
il est mort il y a un mandat d'arrêter
en plus et en Ukraine ça on est où alors
on est toujours au point mort ça veut
dire que les économies ont obtenu
quelques gains de territoire mais depuis
trois mois ni les années les autres
n'arrivent pas à gagner et les Russes
ils ont essayé ils ont amené avec la
société la fameuse société Wagner ils
ont amené même les prisonniers des
prisons mais ils perdent mille personnes
par jour
mais il s'en fiche Poutine à mobiliser
presque un demi million de personnes il
a du mal d'ailleurs à les armer il a plu
même de chars moderne
on dit toujours que c'est c'est une
catastrophe pour la Russie mais bon la
guerre est toujours en cours donc on
peut pas parler de catastrophe parce que
la Russie c'est un énorme pays et donc
même à ce point-là ils peuvent durer
cette guerre ça fait déjà 9 ans ça fait
9 ans elle a commencé en 2014 et donc
s'ils ont tenu 9 ans ils peuvent encore
tenir un an ou deux ans et ça dépend
surtout quelle arme l'Occident fournit à
l'Ukraine le problème c'est que c'est
quoi aujourd'hui les les relations entre
la France et la et la Russie entre
Poutine et Macron il y en a pas assez
toujours il se parlait tous les jours à
un moment c'est fini c'est fini donc là
c'est une route parce que Poutine s'est
moqué de Macron et Macron
bah elle a dit le petit président en
français qui qui se croyaient que ils
pouvaient m'influencer etc enfin si il
s'est moqué un peu d'accord il doit plus
tout contact non non et surtout que du
coup le président Macron a fourni même
les chars léger bon léger AMX 10
français et ça a poussé d'ailleurs les
États-Unis et l'Allemagne a fournir les
gros chats donc là on est quand même à
l'armement lourd vous vous souvenez il y
a un an on parlait de casque et de
protection de gelée par balle maintenant
on parle d'avion de gros avions voilà
donc en fait le conflit bien évidemment
il y a l'escalade dans ce conflit
d'ailleurs je vais faire une petite
publicité dans deux mois je sors mon
prochain livre qui va s'appeler
l'escalade bah tu viendras tu viens ça
se passe à la montagne
et juste Sergueï
petite question et on parle beaucoup de
la santé de Vladimir Poutine alors on
entend tout et n'importe quoi est-ce que
tu as vraiment des infos ou est-ce que
voilà tout ce qu'on entend c'est c'est
du délire il y a quelque chose qui
extraordinaire l'année dernière vous
m'avez posé la même question sur ce
plateau plusieurs reprises mais
qu'est-ce que je vous ai dit tu as dit
je vous ai je vous ai dit que il était
vieux et peut-être malade mais je vous
ai dit tout de suite que François
Mitterrand avec son cancer a tenu de
cette ténor c'est vrai c'est vrai ou
c'est faux c'est vrai et ben les gens
ont retenu la première chose en disant
vous nous avez annoncé que Poutine
allait crever sauf que j'ai jamais dit
ça j'ai dit que comme bien évidemment
que n'importe quelle personne qui a
dépassé 70 ans et là un certain nombre
de maladies mais ces maladies il peut
peut-être tenir encore 10 ans parce que
il a quand même tous les médecins du
Monde il a tous les médicaments du monde
mais bien évidemment on se pose quand
même des questions et mais il est malade
ou pas alors sinon tu sais ou pas et il
a un certain nombre de maladies d'accord
il peut faire appel à des sosies ou pas
quand on a commencé déjà avec vous de
parler de ça on nous traitait de Guignes
de clown etc n'importe quoi et en fait
actuellement il y a même les instituts
sérieuses les services secrets et les
instituts de d'études de la guerre qui
disent ce n'est pas impossible qu'il
utilise ça et par exemple là la semaine
dernière il s'est passé un déplacement
donc il a il a fait un déplacement et
sur les trois points dans lesquels il
était
moi je suis sûr que assez basse people
c'était un sosie de Poutine c'était ce
n'était pas Poutine
l'argument on connaît Poutine on
l'utilise avec la enfin on étudie avec
la loupe on sait depuis 23 ans que quand
il marche et là une démarche très
particulière on a l'impression qu'il a
un sabre qui lui pendouille à la droite
et que avec sa main droite il a il
retient ce sabre donc il ne bouge
quasiment jamais son bras droit d'accord
et là Sébastopol il y a quelqu'un qui
faisait ça
et donc c'est pas petit curieuse méthode
ne changez pas pendant 23 ans vous avez
une manière de de marcher tu penses
vraiment il y a vraiment des sosies il y
a beaucoup de sosies de parking on parle
de deux ou trois
Castaldi il a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui
bah c'est un sosie tu vois
dernière dernière petite question alors
bien sûr c'est ce qui revient l'esprit
de tous tout le monde parle de Troisième
Guerre mondiale avec tout ce qui se
passe actuellement est-ce que on Ukraine
est-ce que on a l'impression on a
l'impression qu'il y a eu un escalade
vraiment un moment et on s'est dit ça
devient de plus en plus chaud on a
l'impression que ça se tempère un peu
entre la Russie les autres pays ou bien
c'est juste une impression non c'est
juste l'impression d'accord on est
actuellement dans un
dans un moment stable mais le problème
c'est que si jamais d'ailleurs j'ai
commencé déjà à dire l'année dernière
c'est que ce qui me fait peur si si
jamais l'Ukraine gagnait parce que si
l'Ukraine gagné c'est là au Poutine
serait acculée et peut-être même tenté à
utiliser l'arme nucléaire d'accord donc
là et là ça et là on s'approche on
s'approche de ça d'où l'escalade